un match de gala au palais des sports de
plaisir les moins de 18 ans du sky vgp
recevait pour la première fois les
féminines du paris 92 plus de 600
supporters avaient pris place en
tribunes pour cette rencontre
une élite le spectacle était également
rendez vous sur le terrain la mi temps
les jeunes handballeurs mendy 7 à 13
après un premier acte plein d'intensité
bon match on a des bonnes choses en face
ça joue bien techniquement elles sont au
dessus de nous mais c'est vrai que
physiquement on n'est pas mal du coup on
arrive à rattraper l'écart en deuxième
période l'écart se creuse entre les
joueurs locaux survoltés dans leur salle
et le pari 92 diminuée par l'absence de
onze joueuses ce camp final de cette
rencontre amicale 34 à 28 son plus grand
et plus costaud plus lourd plus rapide
plus vive
ils sont 60 sur le banc
on n'avait aucune chance à mon dieu le
match mais sa masse de travail de 7 à 15
ans qu'on arrache le plus joué sur la
trajectoire de balle après on a pas qui
est tombée comme un peu plus puissant
très facile d'en faire un bon match de
la globalité et je trouve ça super
intéressant on en plante lendemain
accuse ses parfums et le souhait de
l'entraîneur du sky vgp pourrait être
exaucé d'autres rencontres entre les
féminines du paris 92 des jeunes
yvelinois pourraient être programmées
dans le futur